there is nothing like a site of an  amputated spirit there is no prosthetic  for that everybody's out of work or  scared of losing their job we don't go  out anymore slowly the world we're  living in is getting smaller and all we  say is just leave us alone well I'm not  good to leave you alone now you can  either accept that or you can get to  work  you busy living you get this he died the  night is darkest just before the dawn  and I promise you the dawn is coming  it is with passion courage of conviction  that we take our next steps into the  world  let's go we must find our way look after  one another to live by each other's  happiness not by each other's misery it  may sound easy but nothing to be harder  it ain't about how hard you hit it's  about how hard you can get bit they keep  moving forward  so your story does have a happy ending  but that's up to you